[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
k
frère
[Musique]
anne k
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
sur la route
suivent
[Musique]
sur la route au
bba
[Musique]
v
et
bon
[Musique]
oui
hélas
[Musique]
si nintendo fna
jadis broken wings j'aime tout flamme
oh
aulas
m
[Musique]
l'atb ceni de ted of nine
tb soccer int aussi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oyonnax
ou alors doucement
[Musique]
tapez sur nos systèmes
tombé que tout le monde aime le soleil
darde jeux vieux désir
je perds beaucoup
toussaint ou faire le 100 laine le
soleil là
[Musique]
delors intelligent de soldats
m
jean la même couleur aux gens gentils
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
[Musique]
les verts
c'est
eynaud
rires
e
je sais je suis le mal aimé
[Musique]
ça
mais ont-ils cherché à savoir 2
des joints et pourquoi ce désespoir
caché au fond de moi là je suis mal aimé
je suis
gens me connaissent savent que je mens
mais ont-ils cherché à savoir d'où
viennent mes joueurs
et pourquoi ce désespoir cacher
[Musique]
je suis mal aimé je suis là
tel que je me
montrer mais ont-ils cherché à savoir
[Musique]
morize
tous les sports
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sachez le
pour m
m
je suis
[Musique]
à sb et
hayek
[Musique]
ok
m
[Musique]
oh oh oh
oh
[Musique]
oooh
on l'attend pas
[Musique]
oh
bakou
[Musique]
j'ai trouvé c'était bienvenue chez guy
béart et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu